des documents longtemps convoité plus de
6000 pages de déclaration d'impôts qui
couvrent 2015 à 2020 mines une fois de
plus l'intégrité de Donald Trump on
apprend que dans l'ensemble avait des
comptes à l'étranger on apprend qu'il y
a des années où on n'a pas payé d'impôts
des années aussi déficitaires avec une
fortune évaluée à plus de 3 milliards de
dollars selon le magazine Ford l'ancien
président n'a pourtant rien versé au
Trésor américain en 2020
contrairement à ce qu'il prétendait en
campagne il n'a déboursé qu'un million
de dollars d'impôts au cours des trois
premières années de sa présidence
Donald Trump prévient de la difficulté
d'analyser ces informations fiscales
complexes mais on détecte quelques
stratagèmes pour éviter de payer des
impôts en 2016 par exemple son
entreprise d'aviation BTS a déclaré des
revenus de 680 000 886 dollars curieuses
coïncidence les dépenses se sont élevées
à 680 1886 dollars précisément faute de
profit l'entreprise n'a donc pas payé
d'impôts donc on est un peu en montagne
russe quand on regarde les revenus dans
notre chambre le paiement l'impôt même
il y a eu des retours d'impôts quand ça
allait très très mal l'étoile de l'homme
d'affaires à succès Pali alors que la
Trump organization a été reconnu
coupable de fraude début décembre il
aura tout fait pour éviter de rendre
public ces relevés une tradition à
laquelle se sont soumis tous les
présidents depuis Richard Nixon
au terme d'un long bras de fer les
démocrates frappent quelques jours avant
de céder la Chambre des représentants
aux républicains je pense que pour les
démocrates l'objectif est juste de faire
malade en Trump peu importe la façon de
le faire oui on veut quand même la
transparence oui on dit que c'est la
façon de faire depuis les années 70
depuis 8 heures Nixon de donner ses
rapports d'impôts mais au-delà de ça on
s'est dit est-ce qu'il a fait quelque
chose de frauduleux
inutile tentative pour éloigner Trump de
la prochaine présidentielle ici
Jean-Philippe news Radio-Canada Montréal